en mianmar no solo las calles están
bloqueadas la junta militar ordenó el
cierre de internet de todo el país
mientras miles de personas marchaban en
rangún antigua capital y la ciudad más
poblada del país para denunciar el golpe
de estado de esta semana actualización
un corte de internet casi total está
ahora en curso en mianmar los datos de
la red muestran un colapso de la
conectividad al 16% de los niveles
ordinarios a partir de las 2 pm hora
local es probable que el apagón
informativo limite gravemente la
cobertura de las protestas antigolpistas
la junta a primero intentado silenciar
la disidencia bloqueando temporalmente y
facebook el miércoles tras la
prohibición miles de usuarios se
mostraron activos en twitter e instagram
utilizando hashtags para expresar su
posición a la toma de posición hasta que
los militares ampliaron este sábado la
represión a estas redes sociales para
eludir la prohibición muchos birmanos se
empezaron a utilizar redes privadas
virtuales que ocultaban sus ubicaciones
pero la interrupción más general de los
servicios de datos móviles limita ahora
gravemente al acceso a informaciones
independientes
no tenemos acceso a ninguna noticia
ninguna noticia sobre la madre ann
sanssouci me siento tan triste que me
duele el pecho
la ong human rigths watch pidió el
levantamiento de las restricciones de
internet mientras una portavoz de
twitter dijo que la prohibición socava
la conversación pública y los derechos
de la gente a hacer oír su voz